so with it being very apparent that
Ragnar occurs upon us in future code of
war games to come how exactly what a
trace and Kratos in the Norse world I
have previously made a video discussing
the events of Ragnar and how they
transpired in Norse mythology but will
this be no code of war game and slightly
things will differ slightly so here are
my theories on how the events will go
down in game so we know that the first
sign of Ragnar is the death of the
called Boulder which is something that
does happen by the end of the game and
much like in Norse mythology Loki
doesn't directly kill Boulder but
instead orchestrates the entire process
and can definitely be held responsible
creating a spear or an arrow made from
mistletoe and convinced in the vanguard
Hodor to throw the spear this is fairly
similar to what we see over at Reyes who
may not have killed Bordeaux but he was
responsible for returning him to a state
where he could be killed by his father
Kratos the second sign of the coming of
Ragnar could be a long cold winter that
will last three years known as
fimbulwinter and where the world would
be plagued by war and where brothers
were killed brothers now this winter
already appears to be on its way as
Balder dies and in his death scene in
some very deliberate foreshadowing we
see a pair of snow flakes land on the
cheek of Boulder with the last thing he
says before he dies being the words snow
showing us that winter is indeed coming
this is the latest somewhat confirmed
during a conversation between Brock and
Sindri when they are discussing the end
times and Brock mentions that he feels
fimbulwinter has come Mamere then
explains the crater Senate race that
femorals Wintour's not prophesized to
happen in front of a hundred more years
but because of their actions it has
indeed come early the second part
referring to brothers killing brothers
is something I'm sure we'll also see
with perhaps a few of the icy and then a
god sighting against Odin of craters and
trace the next sign of Ragnarok would be
when the Red Rooster known as Fiala
meaning the evil Noah would warn the
Yona or the giant said of Ragnarok has
begun at the same time the unnamed
rooster that resides in hell would also
warn the dead of the war and the red
rooster known as Gulen Camby would also
warn the gods of Asgard
this is something we may see at the end
of the next game or perhaps the
beginning of the third installment the
many believe that the giant bird we see
in Hell to actually be the unnamed red
rooster that warns the dead the God home
that would then sound his mighty horn
alert in all of the fallen of Valhalla
bringing them back to life for one final
battle now this is definitely an
interesting point of discussion if we
make the assumption that more gods and
goddesses will die at the hands of
trace and Kratos than Heimdall's whom
may bring back Boulder Magnum OD and any
other God that has been previously slain
for one final epic battle hime does home
about one more time but this time it was
to signal the owner or the Giants been
led by such as they stormed across the
Rainbow Bridge into Asgard I do think at
this point the game will once again
differ from traditional Norse mythology
with it only making sense that it's
either crater sore at Reyes leading the
Giants into Asgard but I still think the
fire I'll assert or at least his flaming
sword will still have some kind of role
to play throughout the game were led to
believe that most if not all of the
Giants have indeed been slain by Odin
and Thor but I think it become very
apparent in the next game that many of
them have actually gone into hiding and
there's a good chance a portion of the
next game we spent reuniting them once
they discovered that a trace is a son of
laughs eh I can see the Giants uniting
under the belief that crater sand at
Reyes were aid them in end in Odin's
rain it's said that when the two wolves
skaaland hottie the bringers of night
and day who totally chased the sun and
moon who finally devour their prey they
will send the world into darkness and
mark the very beginning of Ragnarok
during one of his stories Mamere does
mention that Odin captured the two walls
when they were very young and cast them
into the sky knowing that they would
mark the beginning of Ragnarok Odin
thought by controlling them he could
control when Ragnarok begins but as
we've already seen Odin's plans have
been somewhat disrupted and I wouldn't
be surprised to see a trace and crater
set in the two walls free as a precursor
to the final game the children of Loki
certainly play a significant role in
Ragnarok with Fenric killing Odin your
leg and slain Thor and he'll bring an
army of the Dead to storm as god
Petraeus and Kratos encounter and finra
after he has been bound and chained by
Odin out of fear and choosen to set the
wall free something I can definitely see
happening in the next game the three
children we've just mentioned along with
the eight-legged horse known as slip
near war regarded as the children of
Loki now whether that will be the case
in game whether they'll be given a
different backstory and explanation
completely is something that we can only
really theorize about at this point but
I am fairly certain that they will
feature in a game sometime before during
Ragnarok now I do think the outcome of
Ragnarok and God of War will definitely
differ from what we see in traditional
Norse mythology I think there will be
chaos and destruction but I don't think
the world will be destroyed and reborn I
think the folks will be very much on end
in Odin's tyranny now whether that comes
with Odin dying or
seen the error in his ways and changing
remains to be seen but with this being
God of War my money would be an Odin
having his head caved in by Kratos much
like what we saw was loose in the
previous game if you guys have any ideas
and theories and regards to what will
happen in future games then feel free to
share them with me in the comments below